- Okay people.
I'm here today on this,
it's a real hot day today.
You know, I kinda wanna talk
about some demoralizing things
I did under the influence
of alcohol and drugs.
I am a drug addict.
I am an alcoholic.
For those of you who
don't know, that means
that I cannot control, once I take a hit,
once I take a drink, I
cannot control what I do.
Everything that I, everything that I say
I'm gonna, everything I say I'm gonna do,
if I take a drink or a hit before I, prior
to doin' it, all bets are off.
When I was a child, my first addiction
when I was a child was
basically it actually was,
it was actually sex,
because when I got molested
I liked it.
You know, I liked the way it felt.
I liked when my babysitter
got on top of me
and she started rubbin' her vagina on me,
I liked that shit.
You know, I liked it.
Now, I remember thinkin' that all women,
anybody in my family,
anybody that I was with alone
I wanted to have sex with 'em.
Anybody, 'cause I thought,
'cause I liked it.
So, my first addiction was sex.
I remember when this
thing, this thing would
come on at like 11 o'clock at night,
we had to go to bed early, we
be at my grandmother's house.
This thing would come on at night
that was called Love American Style.
Love American Style would
come on and I heard,
they would always talk sex to each other
and I would always wait
because it was like,
I would wait because I wanted to see 'em.
I just thought they were
gonna have sex on it.
I just wanted to see it, 'cause I walked
in on one of my cousins
one time havin' sex.
He was doin' it to his
girlfriend doggy style.
I was lookin', I was like goddamn, I think
I kinda did one of them.
Anyway, that's my first
time doin' one of them,
the first time gettin' one off, so.
I really liked sex then.
So anyway, as time progressed on I had,
I had, now go back, I was, my self esteem
was messed up because my
dad was always tellin' me
that I wasn't shit, I wasn't
this, that and the other.
I was thinkin' 'bout this the other day
because my best friend,
I'm gonna call him R Ron,
we were all in, we were
about six year old,
we were all in a huddle of people
and they were fighting.
You know how guys are.
Okay, you're gonna fight.
I was always afraid, a big
sissy, a big pussy, sissy,
just scared of fightin', you know.
So they were all fighting in the street
and then he looked at,
Louis, you stand back
because, because you can't fight.
I had these big thick glasses on.
You wear big thick glasses, man.
You can't fight.
So I said, oh, I was scared anyway.
I said well good, now I can get out of it.
Now I don't have to fight.
I'll just say I wear
glasses, nobody can hit me,
nobody can beat me up, you know.
So, as time went on, there's this one guy
wanted to become my best friend
and he would beat me up.
You know, he would literally
hit me and beat me up.
I mean, he would grab
me by my collar, man,
and he would take me.
We're gonna go steal a pizza, man.
We're gonna, mother fucker,
we're in elementary school
and one day we cut classes.
We were actually goin' to the pizza place.
I was actually gonna, I
was so scared of this dude
I was actually fuckin' gonna do it.
He said, no man, I
wouldn't make you do that.
Are you really?
So he did to me, like
I's in the fourth grade.
So there's this girl named
Gail and we were walking
up the stairs and he told her,
he said, look man, he said, watch me.
I'm gonna punk Louis, and watch,
he ain't gonna do nothin'.
So he hit me in the side, boom.
He hit me hard in the side.
She turned around and looked.
She said, Louis, you gonna
let him punch you like that?
You a sissy, I'm gonna tell all the girls
in class you a sissy.
So I hit him back.
I hit him back kinda hard.
He said man, that's all you
had to do in the first place.
This guy became my best friend.
This guy became my very very.
We were friends, we were
buddies all the way up.
We were just buddies, buddies, buddies.
(mumbling)
I'll get up there later.
So, like I said, my first
addiction was the sex thing.
So I got about, I don't know so years
and I went into the liquor store
and I saw, I saw a Club magazine.
Club, had all these white girls
with these big fat asses.
Them white girls with them big fat asses.
I always liked them white girls
with them big fat asses.
So I bought one of those books
and by this time I was
livin' with my grandmother.
So I stayed like down in the dungeon like.
So and I didn't realize it, but every time
I had a little, had a little halfway job,
every time I'm gonna get paid
I'd get one of them fuckin' magazines.
I must've had 200 of them son of a bitches
stashed all around,
stashed up under the table,
stashed here, stashed here, stashed here.
Oh my God, oh my God.
So anyway, that's I'm gonna
go back a little bit now.
My first, my first, I was
17 years old and Jimmy Straton handed me
a joint at a party.
I hit the joint.
He said, oh, oh Louis, I
thought you were L seven.
You're cool now.
Well, I had always thought I was,
I'd always had a low self esteem.
I'm a nobody.
I'm sorry, I can't play sports.
You know, I'm scared of the girls.
I'm scared to talk to girls.
And I never did just
think I could be anybody.
I've always had just a
really really fucked up
self esteem, really low low low low,
just a sorry, you know.
So, and then, all my
friends and my brothers
and sisters, they would always tell me,
you're dumb, you're stupid, you're sorry,
you're lame, you're no good.
And so, this kinda stuff, the average,
I think what they were
doin' was they were tryin'
to reverse me.
They were tryin' to make
me you know, stand up,
get some balls and be different.
But, I took it to heart.
And in my, I'm still here.
I still feel like that when I'm not drunk.
I still to this day have to get drunk
to talk to a girl.
Oh yes.
Okay anyway, so where was I?
I was back, I'm goin'
back, I'm goin' back.
So, I became an alcoholic
and first thing I did, oh my God.
This lady really liked me a lot,
big healthy lady, she liked me a lot.
She had bought me all these gold chains.
I was drinkin', always had 100.
Now my father used to beat
my mother all the time,
beat my mother's ass all the time.
Oh, I said I would never
do anything like that.
I would never fuckin'
So, this girl grabbed
the chains off my neck.
She was so big, she was a big girl.
I always liked big women.
She was about 200 pounds.
She grabbed my chain and scratched my neck
and then she slapped me in the face.
Her hand was so big
felt like a man hit me.
Bam.
So, my reaction was I hit her, I hit her
and I hit her and I hit
her, I hit her hard.
I hit her, I hit her.
She weighed about 200.
I knocked her about four or five feet
and she flew at me like this.
And she had this purse
that she had just bought.
She had this great big brother
who weighed about 300 pounds
and played football for
the, for the Verbum Dei
High School and he, and I could hear him
comin' out the door.
I'm gonna kill you, mother
fucker, I'm gonna kill you.
So I jumps in my car
and I take off runnin'
and I'm scared to death.
And everywhere I went,
every see 'cause we were all
like in the same neighborhood
and everywhere I went I would see him.
He had this big black Cadillac,
this big black spooky lookin' Caddy.
He would always come up behind me.
I know, they talk about how he carry guns.
I was afraid he was gonna shoot me.
So anyway, my buddy,
Stan, had took me down
to the HQ and he bought,
he had a .22 pistol
and he had me buy the bullets
for his gun in my name.
So, 'bout the fourth
time they came up to me,
you know, I'm scared, but you know anybody
you can push to a wall and push and push,
push a dog to the wall,
he's gonna start growlin'.
I said, fuck this shit.
I'm gonna fuck him up.
So I go to Stan's house
and I get the pistol.
I says Stan, I'm cryin'.
Danny get me.
He said, what's wrong with you, man,
you're goin' crazy.
Give me the pistol.
Give me the fuckin' pistol.
Don't know nothin' about a gun,
ain't never shot a gun,
got my ass out there.
So I knew they were up there doin'
(mumbling)
So I drove the car and I remember,
I remember when I, when
I backed the car up,
there's the glass at McDonald's over here
and I backed the car up, you know.
And they're in the McDonald's
and they sittin' there
and one of 'em lookin'.
And I told one of 'em go like that.
I get out the car and I go I walk
up in the McDonald's and I go,
I got the tip of the pistol
in my pants.
I raised up and said now,
let me tell you somethin'.
This gonna be the last time
either one of you mother
fuckers fuck with me.
I said, I said, I did hit the lady.
I said, yeah, I said, she hit me first.
I said, I apologize.
I said, I'm sorry for hittin' your sister.
I'm really sorry.
I said, I'm really really sorry.
I said, But, I'm not gonna
take this shit no more
out there, I'm not goin' out there
what the gangster do in the movie.
I'm not gonna take this shit.
Man, I was shakin' like, I'm shaken'
like a mother fucker scared
they're gonna kill me.
And that was that.
But, that was the first
thing that I had done.
And then, my step-mother had two sons
that went with us and I remember
I had lost my job
and I had my last little
change in my wallet
on my bed and I came home
my little step-brother had took my money
outta my wallet.
And I beat him up.
I beat that, he was a kid, oh my God.
So his mom called my daddy at work.
She says, Louis is overreacting.
The goddamn fool done
put his hands on my kid,
I don't know why.
I've never seen Louis act like that.
Louis, I've never seen him act like that.
He said, put him on the phone.
So he told me, he said, get 'yo shit
and get the fuck outta my house.
He said, if I come home
and you're not there,
get 'yo shit.
I don't give a fuck where you go.
He didn't, he didn't give a fuck
about what, what, he never
asked me what happened.
It was just get the shit, get the fuck.
He never asked me what happened.
I said, goddamn, why don't my dad love me?
So then, so we were talkin' one day
and I end up leavin' the house.
I never, I never stepped my daddy's house.
Matter of fact, I had a little 240Z car
and I slept in the back of my 240Z
until my girlfriend, the big girl,
allowed me, I was sleepin' under her bed.
You know, she stayed at her mama's house
and I slept under her bed.
God know, if her mother caught me.
Her mother couldn't stand me.
So, one day I was climbin'
through the window
and the Sheriffs, the Carson Sheriffs
come around the corner and they see me
hoppin' through the window.
They say, hey, what
the fuck are you doin'?
I'm like I got my ass halfway
through the window lookin'
and they, so they comin' to get me.
They got me, gaffel me up, just like they
always do us and they put me on the grass,
had my face all in the grass and shit.
So, she run, no no no no
no, he's my boyfriend,
he's my boyfriend, he's comin' to spend,
he's really comin' to
spend the night with me.
They were cool.
Okay, we're sorry.
But man, I had so much grass and shit
in my face, look like
I'd been playin' football
or some shit.
But anyway, that was
another demoralizin' thing.
But, here comes, here
comes, my best friend,
back to my best friend.
I had ended up gettin' apartment.
I had 'em get me a little
small little apartment
and my buddy came over to, he had just,
he had a really, he had a class,
he had a '69 Volkswagen.
He sold this '69 Volkswagen.
He knew we were drinking,
but he didn't know, he didn't know nothin'
about no drugs.
I kept that hidden.
So he came to my house.
He said man, he told
his mama, I'm gonna stay
with Don, Donnie got his own apartment.
I'm gonna stay with Don
and he gave me, he gave me $40
to put in my coat pocket
for groceries the next day.
Groceries are pretty cheap.
So, he said, I sold the bug,
let's go buy us a hooker,
take her to the house.
Let's toss her up, flip her this way,
flip her that way, you do the back,
I'll do the front.
We keep on goin' til we do it.
So as we were drinkin',
we were drinkin' Hennessy
and I was drunk and the
dope talk to, the dope
talk to me.
The dope said, hey man, he was, he was,
she was, she was suckin',
he was suckin' my dick
and I was fuckin' her
and my dick went soft.
My dope say hey man, huh uh, let's go get,
while they're fuckin', let them fuck
and we'll go get some dope.
Let them do that.
So I did that.
And I went to get the
dope and again the girl
told me, he said come with me to take
the girl back home.
I didn't wanna, I wanted a hit so bad.
I needed a hit.
No, what's wrong with you dog.
He said, what's wrong with you Louis.
Come on man, come with
me to take the girl home.
No, no, so when they got out
he happened to leave his wallet.
Oh my God.
He left his wallet on that counter.
And I said, why did he do that?
Why, but I'll be cool.
I'll take one hit, I'll take one hit
and I'm not gonna fuck with his wallet.
Shit, I went through about
two or $300 of his money.
And so, he comes home and he gets up
to go to work the next day.
He said man, my money
is funny in my wallet.
Man, I wanna know what the
fuck happened, you know.
Don, you my best friend.
What happened?
Did you take my money or did I lose it?
So he came back that
night, he had a girlfriend.
He had this black girl from Compton,
some black ghetto girl from Compton
who's, so I told him, I said hey man,
I said man, I think I have
a drug problem, you know.
I took your money and I spent it on drugs.
God, that hurts me so bad.
Now, now, my best friend had sickle cell.
That hurt him so bad
that I did him like that
'cause we were tight.
It hurt him so bad that he got sick
and he went to the
hospital for about a month,
for about a month he was in the hospital.
That's how, that's how,
he couldn't believe
that I would do him like that.
And his poor mother, his mother had been
and she couldn't believe that I would,
that I would screw him over like that.
So they were, before
he went to the hospital
they were sittin' in my apartment
and I had, I had called my grandmother.
My grandmother gave me
$250 to pay the rent.
The rent was only $350
and she gave me $250, so I gave it to him.
I felt so bad I gave it to him, you know.
And I end up gettin'
put outta the apartment,
so I end up goin'.
(mumbling)
Then so, oh, that's what I wanted to say.
That's when I went to
stay with my grandmother.
My poor grandmother.
Oh God.
One day I was high
and my poor grandmother left her purse
on the side of the couch
and I took $40 out of her purse.
God damn.
I took, that hurt her so bad.
That hurt my grandmother so bad.
My grandmother cried.
My grandmother, when she got hurt,
when she really was in pain
she would sing, you know.
She could sing really good.
She was almost 100 years old and she would
start singin', and I said grandma,
I have a drug problem, sorry.
I told the truth.
Grandma, I got a drug problem.
I'm sorry I stole your money.
I don't know how.
So, I'm still down in the room smokin'
and she comes down in there and she's
don't worry about it, baby,
you told me the truth.
I love you, you told me.
That's what hurt, 'cause
she didn't get mad.
I felt like she should've shot me,
beat me or somethin'.
She didn't, said baby,
you told me the truth.
I'm gonna call your dad and get some help.
I was like oh no, don't call dad.
Oh my God.
I just knew my dad was gonna kill me.
Now, my father was the kinda guy,
he was a hard ass.
He was always on my ass
about bein' too slow,
bein' too dumb, bein' too this.
He was like a big coach.
No, you did this wrong.
No, you did that wrong.
No, you're never gonna be this.
No, you're never gonna be that.
I never seen my daddy soft.
Didn't think he loved me at all.
He came to the house.
God bless him, he's dead.
He came to my grandmother's house.
I was sittin' on the bed.
He pulled a chair up beside the bed
and he did like this
and just started cryin'.
I never seen my, he said,
it's my fault.
He said, it's my fault.
He said grandmother told
me you have a drug problem,
you stole her money.
He said, it's my fault and I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry that I treated you like this.
I'm so sorry.
And I was thinkin' to myself,
it's not 'yo fuckin' fault.
I picked it.
Then I thought to myself,
well hell, I got issues.
Now here mother fucker,
it is 'yo goddamn fault.
I was like yeah, mother
fucker, it's 'yo fault,
yeah, it's 'yo fault.
And I just keep doin' it.
Anyway, he and my
step-mother, well, I know
a program they could put him in.
So, they gonna take,
now they gonna take me
to see, now, I'm missin' bright.
Now they gonna take me
to see this psychologist.
Now they gonna take me to this.
My dad worked for big aerospace.
He had, he knew some people.
He took me to this
psychologist, lady psychologist.
In fact, she was fine.
I'm lookin' at her titties thinkin'
about what I can do to her.
And first thing I asked her, I said,
have you ever hit a crack pipe?
Have you ever take OAZ 800,
been out all night long?
Have you ever hit a crack pipe?
I say, if you ever hit a crack pipe, I say
I hit a crack pipe, when I was 19
I let a homosexual suck my dick
when I was smokin' crack.
I didn't have no more money, no more dope,
I let him, I said, can I
tell you shit like that?
Would you be normal?
She goin' like.
I say, I wouldn't, so I told my dad,
I don't wanna talk to my
psychologist, no psychologist.
So then, they end up takin' me to this
really really really
richie richie program.
You know, I still had a sports car
and I go there and I'm goin',
I had my clothes on.
I remember me and one of the guys
I was hangin' with was tellin' me,
we're in AA.
We're goin' to AA.
You can still do what
you do, you just can't
pick up a drink.
So, I went to the bar and I said,
give me a Long Island Iced Tea.
He said, no no, you can't
drink dude, you're in AA.
No no, I have a crack problem,
I don't have an alcohol problem.
See, here was, I was deluded right there.
Well, I have a crack problem.
But the alcohol is not really a problem.
Just not really a problem.
Now, he slid the Long
Island Iced Tea down.
Anyway, I started drinkin' again.
Lo and behold I rented the car out.
Oh my God.
I rented, I rented, I
had a really nice 260.
I rented my car out and I could hear,
I put, I had the glass pack
mufflers on it and I could hear
my fuckin' car goin' around
the whole fuckin' city
and I couldn't catch the mother fucker.
So the next day came over.
So, my grandmother said,
she called the police.
She said, you know, old folks are smart.
Boy, you know who got that goddamn car
and you're gonna tell them sheriff
who got the damn car.
I say okay.
So I say, yeah, Big Red got the car.
Okay.
They went to Big Red house.
Big Red said my sister.
He said they gonna bring the car back,
so I hear the car rooooooom,
comin' down the street.
I got the car back, wasn't no big thing.
I was like okay, I got
away with it that time.
So then, my dad took me to this place
in Canoga Park to go to rehab.
They put me in the rehab
and I'm, I was, I like
to drive forklift trucks.
Like I will drive, I will drive 'em easy.
I can drive any fuckin' thing.
They put me on the forklift, put me
in access yard where donations come
in for the Salvation Army.
There was guys come from Mexico
and they buy little different things.
And you know, I thought I'm
gonna start sellin' this shit.
So I'm sellin' all the people shit.
I'm sellin' all the Salvation Army shit.
So, they found out and they kicked me out.
They gotta call my father.
He say, your son fuckin' up,
you gotta come get him.
We're puttin' him out.
My father said, I'm done with him.
I'm through with him.
Put his ass out.
So there I am in Canoga Park, way out
and don't have, don't
know how I'm gettin' home.
Came home, went to another program,
the Salvation Army in Santa Monica.
Went out there and got with a guy,
was on a truck with a guy.
He had the Mexicans
come and buy some stuff
off the truck.
He would pay me $40, $50 a
day to keep my, to keep quiet.
One day I stopped at a liquor
store 'fore I went home
and I came back up in
the Sally and the guy
who runs the pay he said, he was so cool,
he said, you drink in a
rehab they put you out.
He said, man you so cool.
He said, man, just go
upstairs and go to bed.
I'm not gonna tell.
Go upstairs.
I said, man no, fuck
that, I got rings, ropes
and shoes, tennis shoes.
I said, once I take a
hit I'm sellin' all that.
I need to go get my shit so
I can sell it 'cause I need
another hit, you know.
So I'm sellin' all this shit, you know.
Then I got this, now I got this,
then I got this girlfriend.
No, now I fucked up in there and I went
to another rehab,
another rehab in Palm Springs.
I stayed there eight months.
I was Jesus, all I knew was Jesus.
We got down, God, God,
don't strike me down dead
'cause I know a lot about the Bible.
And I was so full of the Bible
when I got to eight months
and one day man, I just
needed a hit, you know.
I just, I needed a fuckin' hit so bad.
I couldn't, I didn't
understand where it came from.
I just needed a fuckin' hit man.
I needed a fix.
I'm like, God.
So I had a few dollars saved
up, so I got up and went.
I went out there in Palm Springs
and I took a hit.
And here I am, here's the God, because I'm
only in Palm Springs and I hitchhiked
all the way to Los Angeles,
just with my thumb on the damn 10 freeway.
I don't know, I would never do.
I met a guy on a truck and he's drivin' me
in the truck, you know.
That's when I wanted to drive.
When I saw him, just
when I saw him shiftin'
that truck, I said, that's
what I wanna do, drive a truck.
So anyway, I done beat us in that program.
That's when I came home and my mother
allowed me to stay with her
for the first time since I was.
Anyway, my mother left me
when I was in the fourth.
Me and my mother we
were tight and she left
when I was in the fourth grade.
So, my life was always
fucked up with women
because my mother left me.
I always think that my girlfriends,
they gonna leave me because you know,
my mother left me.
So, my mother let me come stay with her.
I stayed, I stayed with
her for three months
and I started usin'
and she put me in a waterbed and I took
the hot pipe and put it up under
the waterbed all the water came out
the goddamn bed.
She said, what happened to the bed?
Well, it was a hot pipe.
It was a hot goddamn crack pipe.
Oh shit, I'm outta crack.
Well, she ended up puttin' me outta there,
so I'm gonna stay with my brother.
And he had this girlfriend
and my girlfriend told
me that his girlfriend
wanted to fuck me.
I said no.
Oh, she was hot, she was hot.
And I says, no, I wouldn't do nothin'.
So anyway, one day I was drunk
and she came home, she came home
with by herself, her
and my brother went out.
She came home by herself
and she kept tellin'
me, she said like man,
your brother you know,
he's with some other girl
and I'm just so hot I
don't know what to do.
I'm just so hot, I'm just so horny,
I'm just so hot.
I didn't mess with that girl.
But I mean, I sat there.
She said, well I'm gonna go,
she was in there takin' a cold shower.
It took everything.
I just couldn't mess with my girlfriend,
my brother's girlfriend.
I just couldn't do that.
Anyway, he comes home,
he's scrubbin' down.
She was in the shower when he came home.
He's goin' now she's takin' a shower
'cause we had done somethin'.
No man.
So, we had gotten into a fight.
He put me outta his house.
It was pourin' down fuckin' rain.
I'm out in the street one more time.
Got all my shit in goddamn garbage bags.
Here I go again because
of my drinkin' and usin',
the same, one more time.
I went to another rehab.
And, oh this gonna make me huff.
I've been to 68 fuckin' rehabs.
I relapsed from every fuckin' single one.
Let me go back.
When I was with my daughter's mother,
oh my God, poor lady.
I had a nice little job drivin' a truck.
I get paid every Friday.
So, the guy at the liquor
store where I used to go,
he knew, he knew when Friday came
at 6:30 in the afternoon,
when he heard them brakes poppin'
he knew it was me.
I'm fixin' to buy a whole lotta liquor.
I'm in there buyin' liquor.
I'm on this 18, I'm drinkin' liquor
and I'm goin' home and she's comin' home
and then you know, she's
a crack addict, too.
Now we done found out she's pregnant,
she needs to stop.
She needs to stop.
Well, I can't stop bringin'
it home on Fridays,
but this is the thing, this
is what makes me an addict
and an alcoholic.
I told her week after
week after week after week
after, for about, well how long,
I told her for nine months every Friday
I said, baby, this
Friday I'm not gonna stop
at the fuckin' liquor store.
I told her that with everything.
I mean, I was even cryin', baby, I'm not
gonna stop at the liquor
store this Friday.
I'm bringin' all the money home.
But, I mean, I was serious.
I'm serious as a mother fucker.
I'm serious.
The next Friday I gotta,
I got another bottle
and I came home, I say,
baby, I fucked up this week,
but next weekend I'm not gonna fuck up.
I did it week after week after week
after week after week
after week after week.
And as I get on up to the story, I'm just
now realizin' that that's the whole thing
of alcoholism is you just can't,
you just ain't got no power over it.
And the most demoralizing thing
about bein' an alcoholic is
here I am, a man, and here's somethin',
here's this alcohol
and here's this little,
this little yellow rock is
and they have the, I tell
that cocaine is the finest
white woman in the world.
She ain't got no pussy.
She ain't got no face.
She ain't got no lips.
She get all my fuckin' money
and I ain't fucked her yet, you know.
Same thing with the alcohol.
I take a drink of alcohol,
but the craziest fuckin'
shit in the world is
my family, God, just the shit,
just to see my family in pain like that.
But, and the fact that they were thinkin',
they were thinkin' I'm rushin'.
My family was thinking,
my family was thinking,
well, dude you got a kid comin', you know.
Things, you're getting older.
My dad said, you're getting older,
but you're not getting any smarter.
You're just gettin' dumber.
You're just gettin' dumber
dumber dumber dumber dumber.
Well dad, I'm gonna stop doin' it.
Well, grandmama I'm gonna stop doin' it.
Tell my brothers I'm gonna stop doin' it.
I had the girlfriend and I had
the girlfriend in Houston, you know.
We were supposed to go out and I relapsed
and took a hit and she came over,
she say, you do it one
more time, you know,
now I'm gonna do.
Fellows, white girls don't,
black girls take this shit.
White girls, they ain't havin' that shit.
She say, you got one more time.
You have one more time to do that shit.
And look here, the next
time I did that shit,
I went over her house, same thing,
in the rain, all my shit in trash bags,
sittin' on the porch.
Bye, you gotta go.
Here I am, one more time,
out in the fuckin' street,
nowhere to go.
I walked out with my bags.
Oh my God.
So then, I met another girl
and I did her the same.
I met another girl, poor dear, I moved
in the apartment with her,
had her mother, gave her, we was rentin'
a Fleetwood Cadillac.
We were sober.
We were in AA, we were sober.
I relapsed one time, took off
with the fuckin' pickup truck
for three fuckin' days.
Nobody knew where I was.
I was smokin' crack.
I was so high on that goddamn shit
I didn't know how, I thought I was,
I thought I had only been out for a day.
Hell, I'd been out there
for three fuckin' days.
I'd lost about 20 pounds.
I was stinkin'.
And I called her up, I
said, hey dear, what's up.
She said, uh huh, yeah mother fucker.
She said, bring my mother's truck home
and don't bring none of that stuff.
I went home and she let me
back in, but good old Deb,
she was so sweet.
She was in AA.
She was an alcoholic, but she was sorry,
but she kinda let me back in there.
Things didn't work out, you know,
so I just, I just kinda
left her there, you know.
And I really hurt her.
I really, I really hurt
her and her mother, man.
God, she called my dad.
This bitch called my father
and told him, Mr. Banks,
Louis is down here really trippin' man.
He's relapsed on that shit.
He took my mom's truck, you know.
I saw on his.
I had my porno magazines
and my crack pipes in the bathroom
on top of the shelf.
I, to this day, I don't know what made,
I was in the bathroom shavin' my face
and she walked up in the bathroom,
she stood up on the toilet,
she grabs the porno magazines
and the pipe.
She threw 'em on the floor.
What the fuck is this shit doin'
in my mother fuckin' house?
You talkin' about the most
embarrassing humility.
I felt so fuckin' low.
She said, you smokin'
crack and lookin' at porno.
What's wrong with me?
What's wrong with this, you know?
I'm like, baby, nothin' wrong with that.
Every now and then I just like to get off.
She said, well you gotta go.
One more time, I'm out on the street,
got my shit in them green Glad bags.
Well, thank God for Glad bags
'cause Glad bags been keepin' me,
you know, holdin' me up.
I've walked out with
them goddamn Glad bags.
Here I am, one more fuckin' time.
Me and them fuckin' Glad bags.
So anyway, that happened and then I got,
I got a real good job with a guy
who had a truckin' company,
had a big truckin' company.
Now, his daughter liked me a lot.
His daughter was his gem
and she liked me a lot
and she came to my apartment one day
and she had a handful of crack.
Oh my God.
She and I started smokin' crack.
Her father found out and then he said,
well, you have to go to rehab.
So and I went to rehab and I went to rehab
and then she called my father.
Why these bitches always call my father.
You know what, they just like my father.
And then she, she was
keepin' in touch with him.
He even came and he said I came to Houston
lookin' for you.
Your friend told me you were in rehab.
She said her dad bought
you a truck, you know,
and I came back and
then everything was good
and then one day I didn't show up at work.
Three or four days I'm smokin' crack again
and I end up gettin' fired, you know
that would happen.
Now, here comes the day where I guess God
figured I needed a little ass whoopin'
so I was sittin' at the
gas station panhandlin'.
This white guy comes up
in the back of the van.
He got long hair,
he's a guitar player some kinda band.
He said hey man, I need to get some crack.
Show me where the rock is.
Choo, let's get in.
He said, give me $300 worth.
I'm not thinkin' he
could've been the police.
But I mean, I'm a little
bit, I'm a musician.
I knew, I didn't feel like,
he was a real musician,
so we went to the spot where I used to go
to the Mexicans and get the rock
and he opened up the van.
I said hey man, give
us $300 worth of shit.
He looked in there and he said man,
that's the fuckin' police.
He slammed the door.
Guy ended up givin' me $100 for helpin'
him out anyway, so my dumb ass,
I walk back over there to buy the dope,
went on foot.
Here these guys are,
they surroundin' me now.
I'm still not thinkin'.
All I'm I want a hit.
I'm not thinkin' again.
One guy said man, why did you bring
the police to my mother fuckin' spot?
I said, what is, before I could finish,
before I could finish talkin'
bow, he got me in the jaw.
You know, I'm tryin' to run.
They hittin' me and I'm tryin' to run.
And I remember he had, he had a pit bull
and his pit bull named Petie.
He said, get him, Petie.
And I remember, I
remember hearin' the dog.
Man, I don't think, I was runnin' so fast,
goddamn, I was runnin' over here,
I'm runnin' and I could hear the dog,
heard the dog, lookin' back.
And all of a sudden, I don't know,
it's like, it's like, it's like
the fear just left me, dude.
It's like the fear just left me.
Then I turned around and boy I said,
come on mother fucker.
You run up on me I'm gonna bust 'yo,
you think you got a big jaw now, wait.
And the dog just fuckin' stopped
and turned back around and ran back.
But, as I was runnin' from him I fell down
and I remember I busted my hand open.
My hand was split wide open and I went
to the Fire Department
and they laced me up
and they took me to rehab.
Here I am one more time in rehab.
I'm in there I got caught
fuckin' screwin' around,
one of the, screwin'
one of the counselors,
little white counselor.
She liked me, I liked her.
I mean, I got caught screwin' her.
One more time, I'm out on the street.
And these were the blue.
These was the blue, the Hefty,
they had the blue ones
this time, the blue bags.
One more time I'm out
with them fuckin' bags.
I said, what is it about
me and these goddamn bags?
Then, poor Vee, Vee was a lady I met,
went to church one day
'cause hell, I was hungry.
I hadn't eaten in three
days and you go to church
and they feed you.
So, Vee was there and Vee
liked to take men home
and take of 'em.
So she was there, I was
sittin' in the front
of the van there.
She said, God told me
to take you home with me
and let you dry out.
I was like, damn it is a God.
So she took me home with her, you know.
You know her stipulation
with stayin' with her
was she had to read the
Bible, which was cool,
you know, you had to
read the Bible with her
and all that stuff.
And then again, I start
sneakin' my crack in there
and goin' in the bathroom
turnin' the shower
on, smokin' my crack, and she found out.
One more time, I didn't have,
she didn't give me nothin'.
But, my stuff was inside, it was like
in a laundry bag inside the
closet outside the whatever.
Get your basket and get to walkin'.
So now I'm, shit's really
gettin' bad 'cause I ain't got
no bag, I gotta fuckin', now everybody see
I got a fuckin'.
I remember throwin' all my clothes,
brand new boots that she just threw
all that shit in the street.
One more time I'm back
on the goddamn street.
I got depressed and I called my sister.
I said sister, I got to
get the hell outta Texas.
She said, talkin' 'bout
call my, call my, call dad.
Oh, don't call fuckin' dad.
They called dad.
Dad said, well, get him a bus ticket.
I get a bus ticket and I come home
and I'm gonna get sober, for real.
Now y'all, now this
time, this time I'm gonna
really get sober.
I mean, I'm gonna get sober this time.
I'm not bullshitin' this time.
I bullshit y'all them other times.
Goddamn I got fucked up again.
I did it, I relapsed again.
Let me, okay now, this last time around,
so my mother's best friend's daughter,
beautiful gem, we end up dating.
My mother said, don't
date her, don't date her.
Y'all don't want to.
My mother didn't want me to embarrass her
because she knew I was, she
knew I was gonna fuck up.
But, I was, man I got, I got sober, man.
I had the little job.
I had a Saab 93, I had
a blue Saab and I mean
I was, I was good and I felt good,
I looked good.
But, I didn't, I didn't
know what, I didn't know
what an alcoholic was.
I thought I was cured.
Well, about eight months had went by
and my girlfriend was boring as fuck.
She just wanted to sit down and watch TV
and she liked to do
this every now and then.
We gonna go eat, she liked to go eat.
She was beautiful, beautiful woman,
had a lotta money.
She would've made a perfect wife.
But anyway, she asked me one day,
she said, she was a divorcee.
Widow woman.
She said, I'm so happy with you.
When is the bottom gonna fall.
I done told her, oh God, I said, if I ever
take a drink, all bets.
She didn't hear me.
I said, if I ever take a fuckin' drink
all bets are off.
Well, it was the 4th of July.
It was me, it was her mom and my mom
and her and we're all
sittin' in the front porch.
And I said, baby, let's go somewhere
'cause I wanted a hit and a drink
and I wanted a drink and I didn't know.
I didn't know that the alcoholism
was, they call it the sleeping giant.
That mother fucker, he
gets down in your gut
and he falls asleep.
When he wakes up, hey, hey mother fucker,
it's time, let's go,
let's go, let's fuck up
our life again.
Let's fuck life up one more time.
And when he's let's go fuck life up,
but I, I, I had been
sober for a little while,
so I, but I don't know how to live sober.
I remember when I used
to have sex with her
my penis would go soft,
and she would say you
don't even, she was not
and she said, I don't understand.
I don't know how to have sex
without no drugs and alcohol.
So, to be sober and doin' that shit
and I couldn't.
And I said, damn, and I
have a brother-in-law's
a doctor, I say man,
if somethin', do I need
some Viagra or somethin'?
I say, my dick be goin' soft.
And he's well you're of that age now.
I said no, my girl thinks I don't like her
and I'm not attracted to her.
I was, I was, my disease was knockin',
was wantin' to get high.
Fuck that feelin'.
When your disease tell
you when you, when you,
when you, that takes too much energy.
When you just sit back and hit the pipe
it feels just as fuckin' good
and you don't even have to be goin'
through all that and please.
Just please yourself.
That's what the damn
disease is tellin' me.
So I, the voice in my head was really,
it was really really really
really really low voice.
But, and I remember, I stood up.
I stood up, man everybody,
everybody's goin' oh,
what's wrong, what's goin' on?
I said mom, get in the fuckin' car.
Let's go, I'm takin' you home.
I took my mama home.
I stopped at the liquor store
and I didn't think about what I was doin'
til I had, when I had the
bottle of Cisco in my hand,
when I heard the top
go and I saw the smoke
come out the top of the bottle,
like I Dream of Jeannie.
When I saw Jeannie come up out that bottle
and I saw them big titties and big legs,
I said, oh well, and when I did that,
it was a fuckin' wrap.
God, and the poor lady, the poor lady
was callin' me on the phone
and my dumb ass didn't have enough
sense to turn the phone off, and the phone
was for three days dude,
the phone was ringin'
and ringin' and the girl didn't know,
nobody knew where I was
and I'm in the car smokin' crack
in my Saab, ridin' around the 'hood.
I got so high look, I tried to get
the LAPD to take me to fuckin' jail
and the mother fuckers wouldn't take me.
'Cause my car ran hot.
And I said cool, he came
said, are you all right?
I said no no no.
I said my car, I'm not,
I was tryin' to tell him
I got crack in the car,
I got alcohol in the car.
He said, yeah yeah yeah, okay.
He pulled out.
I was like goddamn, I can't
even fuckin' go to jail.
So, that happened and I end up wreckin'
the car and totalin' the car out.
But, I did that poor
lady like that, you know.
And she was even givin' me another chance.
She liked, she liked me a lot, you know.
I said, baby, I said you know I.
And then I got sober for another week
and I relapsed again
and I started relapsin',
relapsin' and finally I said you know,
I left my house.
My landlord came to my house.
I had a BMW, my landlord came
to my house talkin' shit.
I had my rent money in my pocket.
The disease was tellin'
me, fuck that bitch.
Man, let's go get high.
Fuck that bitch, leave.
We can sleep in the car.
Fuck, this is what the
dope was tellin' me.
We can sleep in the, man, we can sleep
in the mother fuckin'
car, we'll be all right.
Then we ain't gotta pay no rent.
Then we can smoke the
whole goddamn $500 a month
every month, every month, do like we want.
We can get strawberries,
get bitches in the car
and suck our dick and all this shit.
Fuck it, I listened, listened
to that mother fucker
one more time.
There I am.
I left the house.
No, I left the keys to my
car on my brother's bed.
I left the car at his house.
I had a really nice vehicle.
It was old, it was a classic, it was old,
I left it at my brother's
house and I left.
Nobody heard from me
til three months later.
Could you imagine 'yo people,
they didn't know whether I was dead
and the poor, the girl,
my mother, everybody
was upset and then I called 'em one day
and they told me that my brother had died.
I have a brother was a police officer.
He died, you know.
But, they, once they heard my voice
they weren't mad at what I had done,
but they were just glad that I was alive.
So I told 'em this big,
this I never told nobody.
I told 'em this big fuckin' lie
that I went, I went
legally insane and forgot.
I suffered from amnesia.
I forgot who they were, where they were,
what they were and I just started walkin'.
I don't, I don't even think
they believed it, but I told
'em that I had that, I
have a mental problem,
you know, which I know
I have a mental problem,
and I started walkin' and everything.
And I remember, I remember
I got beat up.
I lost the keys to my car.
I got beat up with a Billy club.
I parked my car and I
lost the key to my car.
I went to go get a key, simply came back,
somebody stole my car.
I came down here on 9th.
I laid, I was so, I had
never been that depressed.
I had never, I just wanted to die.
I just wanted, it was nothing in me
that wanted to live.
It was nothin' in me
that wanted to survive.
I just wanted to fuckin' die.
And it was nothin', the preacher, nobody
could say nothin' to make me feel better.
So, I just, I remember I
was, it was like broad day,
everybody's just, and I just laid
on the fuckin' sidewalk and I just said,
God let me just go to sleep.
I just laid on the fuckin' sidewalk.
I remember this little young guy walkin'.
He said, man, what's goin' on?
Tell me what's happening, you know.
And I remember these priests walked by.
They were prayin' for me.
I mean, I had got that damn bad.
So then I started gettin',
I was gettin' my checks man,
I was smokin', I was smokin' up $900,
a $900 a fuckin', when I was drivin'
I was smokin' up $800 or $900 a week.
I get paid on Friday and goddamn by Monday
I didn't have no money.
Since I been gettin' high
I been tellin' myself
over and over and over it's
gonna be different this time.
Next time I'm just gonna get one 20,
I'm just gonna get one bottle of beer.
I'm not, I been sayin' that
shit over and over and over,
til one day, I mean,
we're fixin' to cook here.
In conclusion, there's a preacher told me,
he said, until you realize
that there's nothin' you can do,
nothin' your daughter can do,
nothin' your mother can do,
nothin' nobody on this earth can do
about what you doin' you gonna continue
to fuckin' do it over and over and over
because it ain't, until you realize
there's nothin' you can
do about it or nobody else
can do about your situation.
And that kinda, I kinda heard that.
I was like, Goddamn, that's
what's wrong with me.
I can't not do it.
So they talk about you have to believe
in a power that's greater than yourself.
Now, that kinda made sense.
You know, sometime, you know, I'm human,
you know how we are.
Sometime we believe in God.
Sometime we don't believe in God.
But, in my situation
you have to have faith
in what they teachin',
they tell you that you have
to have faith in somethin' other than you
in order to recover from anything.
You have to talk about
it, talk about, what I'm
doin' here, you have to get it out.
I feel so much better, Mr. Mark.
But, you have to talk about it.
But so now here I am,
I'm kinda thinkin' the right way now
my Social Security couple hundred dollars
short on rent, so I've got
the rent paid last month.
I'm a couple hundred
dollars short on this month.
But anyway, things are kinda goin'.
I'm not usin' as much as
I used to, but I'm still
you know, still sayin' I'm not gonna do
it and doin' it again, but I'm doin'
a little better 'cause
I'm gettin' shit done.
You know, I'm gettin' healthier.
I'm wearing contact lenses and shit now.
Get me a little haircut halfway.
Bitch cut my hair.
I mean I had, it looked
good the first time.
Now, I look like a damn fool.
I said man, if my mother
saw me lookin' like this,
oh my God.
But anyway, here I am now
and I'm realizin' that, that alcoholism
is a disease and most
of the time because we,
and I'm talkin' about me, right.
I punish myself.
I think about the things,
the things I told you
I said I did, I think about those things
and I punish myself.
Well, goddamn you know, it's like the kid
that cuts their own arm off.
Well, I'm doin' the same thing,
but I'm just inducin' drugs and alcohol.
But the same thing as cuttin' yourself.
I'm killin' myself because I feel like
I'm punishin' myself.
And so, the preacher said,
God don't punish you.
Why are you gonna punish you when God
ain't gonna even punish you.
Who are you to punish yourself?
So these things that they was teachin' me
and tellin' me I'm
startin' to hear 'em now.
Maybe, maybe I'm on my
way to gettin' better.
But anyway, I just wanted
to dump that and say
that and I feel super
and a whole lot lighter.
See you guys next time.
Was that cool?